[Music]
perfect you're supposed to say it's
Tuesday though so let's try it again at
this time say it's Tuesday ready 1 2 3 a
mini airport in New York City Hank I'm
at the airport in Washington DC so for
some reason that I don't understand
penguin got me the couples Valentine's
special here at my hotel in Washington
DC so last night I was treated to a
dinner where I got two entrees two
appetizers and two desserts
sorry Weight Watchers and now I'm in the
airport in Chicago I know you're
wondering Hank you're wondering John how
are you getting from airport to airport
are you using a hovercraft are you using
movie magic
no I'm using airplanes and that's
unfortunate because you know what
airplanes hate snow
what's the people here at the moment our
cameraman asking people what it's like
that all the flights are being canceled
so I thought I would recreate one of
those interviews so how do you feel
about all these delays they suck could
you actually could you put my question
back into your answer um all these
delays of my flight suck I think I've
spent 12 of the last 40 hours inside of
airports and you may be wondering how I
passed the time when I'm here and the
answer is simple have been hard at work
on my 2007 celebrity death pool line up
a celebrity death pool is where you pick
24 people who you think will die in the
next year it's really you know it's like
it's like good clean fun it's a way that
I can give back you know the key to
playing the game and still being able to
live with yourself is to pick people
that you're kind of rooting for or at
least that you're ok with the idea I
mean obviously you never want anyone to
die but if people have to and from what
I understand they do they might as well
be members of al Qaeda so I'd like to
say a pre-emptive goodbye to all those I
hope we will be missing come January 1st
2008 this song is for the rat
roll themselves into the ocean when they
saw that the explosives in the cargo
we're just about to blow this song is
for the soil it's toxic clear down to
the bedrock where nothing of consequence
can crush drop your seats there let them
go let them all go
tank I'll see you tomorrow